hey the congressman is back okay all
right so here are the questions Jon
Meacham does the post-civil war era
offer any lessons and how to seize upon
a post trump era to enact real lasting
political and social reform oh we're in
a reconstruction times not really
unfortunately because reconstruction
really was a prelude to a century where
we were still fighting Jim Crow and u.s.
grant got a couple of things right he
fought against the Klan and that was
important but it didn't really didn't
come back until the 20s but the Justice
Department was founded actually to fight
the Klan for the for the first time in
the 1870s I do think this is like
reconstruction in that the most
analogous president which is like saying
the best restaurant in hospital you know
it's a small category because John oh
yeah he was Johnson was trying to undo
the verdict of the war and was doing so
they impeached him so let's get on with
the impeachment okay well you're you
voted against a resolution to request
the president's tax returns you did it
was there wasn't an actual resolution on
our floor but it was a probably a vote a
motion to table but if it comes back on
let me I'm sure I know where the
questions going I think I should see the
president's oh good
that's why we bring Republican terraeum
to that you know okay Jennifer what do
you make of the Senate's latest warming
against warning against precipitous
withdrawal from Syria does this signal a
shift in Republican pushback against
Trump's foreign policies whatever they
can do is more than they have been doing
which is exactly nothing so every little
bit should be encouraged now perhaps
they can start pushing back on things
like the wall on things like his
non-existent victory over Isis so if
they can smart start in small ways
hopefully this will become a pattern and
a trend I think what is interesting is
that they're no longer completely cowed
by the sky that they have some inkling
of independence some sense of self
survival maybe so this is a good thing
I don't think it's gonna be enough
frankly to save a bunch of them in 2020
someone like Cory Gardner it's kaput but
hey if they want to start and they want
to start actually taking the job
seriously that would be great but
Jennifer don't you think they should go
the next step and actually decide and
vote to authorize our military actions
rather than just letting them happen oh
well you're gonna go back to the
Constitution I mean this is this is that
I hope this leads to a bigger discussion
with all due respect to the congressman
where's the War Powers actually you need
it all these wars have happened without
congressional authorization and somehow
the Congress is not clamoring that's if
I make that destroys a bipartisan to
give up that yes the last time we
declared war was right 2001 was don't
want to declare war right now when you
declare war that means the president
gets these all these powers here in the
United States that's why it's an
authorized use of military force that
that's that's too since we've discovered
now a whole bunch of these emergency
powers which sounds like you know these
things are still on the book some of
them have been on the books for 60 years
we don't even know what they are so to
the mayor's point it used to be like
back when I was a member of the
Republican Party the deep dark ages that
the Republican Party was against it with
all respect wasn't it like two years it
was like 24
used to be the party that didn't like
executive power it used to be the pal
Paul Ryan would give speeches about
Congress requiring the power that was
present yeah come on it's completely
different
George have you bless you're saying that
no no no it's all self we'll always paid
executive power until they have parties
both parties did this let's be clear
both parties in the Congress have
stepped away for the responsibility left
it to the President and this is
something we should be asking questions
about as Americans why are why were we
in Saudi Arabia and wipes you in Yemen
why we already backing Saudi Arabia in
Yemen why were we part of a humanitarian
crisis why were our tax dollars killing
families and children and the Congress
said nothing until very recently
something's wrong with that equation
it's two points here I think Jennifer is
absolutely right that Congress in the
past and again I've only been Congress
for four years so I used that that past
tense has given power to the executive
branch in the Congress is supposed to be
a co-equal branch of government and
that's where they've given too much up
and that's and we're trying to claw some
of that back there was a vote earlier
this week about saying our support for
NATO because NATO has you know been
responsible for 70 years of peace and
prosperity
we're in Yemen because the Iranians were
creating a human human terian crisis in
Yemen right and so so there's no vote by
the Congress to authorize military
support for Saudi Arabia and we know
that salary Arabia exacerbated the
humanitarian crisis there was no actual
debate and vote and that's dangerous
what did you think about the Trump
getting a guy to pass over 30 people to
get security clearance who the experts
said shouldn't have security clearance
someone who well Kushner and third it's
in 30 people who went through the normal
channels which at the top levels is the
old is the CIA and they said no are you
kidding this isn't white collar
criminals they can't I can't I'm
security
clearance there they're up to their
necks with other cut and he found some
stooge to say oh no you have security
clearance I'm pretty confident confident
that the distinguished gentleman from
the state of Maryland Chairman Elijah
Cummings will be investigating that
process and here's what's always funny
is when we actually agree when one
person of one party agrees with some of
the other party we always say be more
like me right but can we just say for
once we're actually in agreement because
making sure we have two strong parties
is important to this country the
competition of ideas is what made has
made this okay but but one party is
enabling Donald Trump and one party is
enabling all these things that we're
talking about the fact that he's able to
get away with giving security clearances
to people who don't deserve them is
because the Republican Party as a whole
is not standing up to him and is
allowing the reason why he gets away
with having meetings with Putin and
nobody gets to take notes I mean what
goes on in these meetings with Putin
it's the Republican Party it's not a
bipartisan than never what he's able to
ride away with this and that's why many
of us who were in the Republican Party
said they have to lose they have to lose
really badly so that they know either
they'll to either start over or some
other party will come up but you can't
have a party that has lost its mind and
lost okay mr. mayor where were you
surprised to learn that the Trump
foundation is being forced to dissolve
after allegedly engaging in a shocking
pattern of illegality the bill I have to
say I did not recover from that report
it was so shocking to me no this is the
guy has been a conman though it's
amazing his back in the 1980s when and
he's done disgusting vehicle for the
execution yes a five young men in the
Central Park five case who were proven
innocent right he took out full-page ads
to call for the execution this guy he
has stiffed his workers
every step along the way in the hotel
industry he's a con man who got away
with it for decades and then we're not
gonna get away with it this time
I hope not okay
you